[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
venir ouais bah sachez que ce sera je ne
pense à rien ça montre c'est évident ça
alors là col du jour c'est très simple
si tu perds tu devras te déguiser sur
facebook lite pendant la pub alors bob
ringard six ans bob ringard et tu devras
faire une animation aux bragards ici sur
le plateau
depuis ce matin on a trois ans de troyes
il y aura trois émissions ouais bah
justement on s'en fout photo d et si on
gagne ce que je gagne
[Applaudissements]
pour que je gagne pas encore cette
émission là qu'est ce que je gagne 6
gagne a dit tu vas me pousser à changer
pas poussé que je veux qu est ce que je
gagne 16 gagne mais qui chialent moins
farouche avec larusso une époque
bah oui pas mal ajouté manalich
arrive un bisou dans le cou déjà à
changer la passion surprise avec 3 on a
trop jours de la fin ils pètent complet
mais ça tu es en train de me demander à
nos micros cacahuètes à ne pas dire
autre chose à deux doigts du racisme
c'est pour les gens savent maintenant
non mais qu'est ce que tu as rien telli
tu peux lui parler stopper allez vas-y
merci fait on interroge calme-toi
séquelles et il fallut paris stopper ça
se mange pas la créer un nom sonnant ce
qui fait que ça clair ou tu la rapière
direct à 2,7 de m'avoir dans le dos
attention question en 2000 a terminé à 0
comme par hasard c'est moi qui a choisi
ya pas de hasard si c'est là bas et j'ai
hâte moi c'est toujours jean nice et
toulon aujourd'hui jean bien avoir dans
le dos j'ai pas non plus aller en 2002
avec michaël youn et benjamin morgaine
et vincent desagnat sur le tube stas
fâchent mais quel était le nom du groupe
oh [ __ ] les énergies ce nom les
compositions des bee gees tâche par les
propositions je barre des propos de m
allez allez au dialogue bratisla boys
les bâtisses la mode au début c'est un
million cinq cent mille si je suis
désolé c'est avant l'explosion va
permette donc c'était way single c'était
une parodie de l'eurovision ça quoi
c'est ouf
dans quel célèbre émission chantal
ladesou s'est elle distinguée dans les
années 90 la classe e le match des trucs
ou fort coup gars c'est quoi je suis fan
de à tous la classe est bien là dessous
bah oui j'adore c'est vrai j'aimerais me
fait un petit canal d'énergie
allez on va s'en tenir à deux cas c est
sans doute le ronnie est de plus en plus
belle c'est l'intimé je te jure on est
autant qu'ils étaient montés ou de marié
ont été maquillés toi j'ai très très
marié non ouais on perd marié 40 ans non
mais ça fait rêver la bouche un coin à
la belle
[Applaudissements]
à
elle n'a jamais été belle job c'était
bizarre parce qu'un talent j'ai failli
vous êtes belge toutes les deux minutes
cette belle je vois pas pourquoi pas de
ce très bien géré on embrasse tous les
belges pourraient très bien mais elle
n'a bien sûr en même temps ouais
est-ce que les belles jambes elle a
[Rires]
toujours gardé un jour là dessous c'est
doux comme un coup de grisou qui depuis
17 ans cherchait laborieusement les
zones érogènes sur le corps de votre
mari j'ai vu demandé à sa secrétaire
chantal à 6 792 savez la garce également
jamais la garde c'est ouais y aller jean
marie bigard y avait la garde vous avez
dit kacou michèle laroque
oui mathieu est un garde sur vos fiches
et dames de faire un doigt d'honneur
alors on attendait qu est ce que vous
avez fait à kelly alors déjà je vous
posais la question mais est-ce que moi
imaginez tricher juste ma part tout de
suite à la démission de m j'ai une
confiance aveugle
oui ouais l élection mais elle est
néanmoins je veux dire autant magath est
une fille bien autant agathe est une
ville tant que riches
[Rires]
oh oui mais dans les vestiaires
en fait il a question sur 900 deux amis
à dole morning live vincent week-end et
benjamin chantez déguisez sur des clips
connu comment s'appelait cette séquence
les tubes de la cave les tubes du
grenier ou le tube de jean michel mr
tubes du grenier mis à mal ah ben je
regarde est exact et moi on se rappelle
t on a fait tourner une petite coupe
dans ce genre ça c'était un stade perruc
à sketches exact
[Musique]
toile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
c'est plaisir la personne la demoiselle
qui faisait les costumes de cette
séquence s'appelle charlie boujari
exactement rien là et qui est maintenant
comédienne examinons en famille c'est
vrai et que c'est elle qui fait je sais
pas si je l'embrassais forge l'adorent
charlie où elle est formidable c'est un
gros bisou c'est vrai que charlie bruno
voilà et voilà qui est parti quand je
suis arrivé hier malheureusement oui
mais voilà je l'adoré
non mais c'est vrai ouais c'est cool
merci radio peut-on attendre
quotidiennement la voix de chantal
ladesou pour vous tous fassiez des
grosses têtes mon chéri j'adore un mini
les fans de vous même c'est vrai que
l'actionnaire des grosses têtes depuis
avril 2010 et y ait d'abord avec
philippe bouvard puisse vous êtes resté
avec laurent ok vous avez fait une chute
suite sur le bateau ouais ouais ouais
c'est regarder c'est seydou c'est
douloureux
ça va mieux depuis mais c'est bien
sympathique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop long
olé
bien sûr ça vous éclater dans les
constats rire ça me laisse beaucoup
c'est vrai qu'ici
eh ben ça me fait plaisir mais l'exemple
des musées bien sonneries sont bons à
prier mais il s'amuse beaucoup
ouais ça m'aide beaucoup qui a vu le
film moi alors major la carte ati à moi
je me suis régalé alors les dialogues
chez j'ai cogité vous qui les avez fait
ça va ou désire vraiment y avait des
réflexions au genre
non vraiment j'ai j'étais c'était fin
comme ce que vous faites dans l'os à oui
c'est possible
c'est très drôle parce qu'il parle de de
boer est là la fougasse il parle de
plein de choses comme ça et le film les
dialogues sont très drôles et c'est vrai
qu'il y avait pensé à bercy bonamassa
rambla que vous les femmes debout et la
fougasse là et pendant je pense que
kenzo non c'est brûle kenzo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
indiqué sa mère c'est jubilatoire
c'est trash c'est méchant c'est corrosif
on jubile devant autant de cruauté c'est
une sorte de tatie danielle post moderne
ça et vous vous êtes chantal comme
d'habitude vous êtes vraiment mais
exécrable wells avait demandé il ya des
punchline non sap et moi la mienne la
préférée c'est je préfère les soirées
votre cas au soir et kaka est une
succession de ses enfants parce qu'elle
déteste ces enfants risquent exactement
ils lui rendent bien
parce que sorti du contexte louis michel
avait gens sont bien habillés et on voit
jamais la perche ce qui est pas de tout
cas ça c'est un film porno on voit la
chose fut libéré ça comment tuer sa mère
sa soeur le stress - chant sort demain
demain sort demain avec un tel atout
vincent desagnat les séries
desertec un gilet désigner quelqu'un qui
va faire beau brun gare à votre place à
braga le pauvre ça fera 2 dans la
semaine de mauvais chez m e gilbert des
débats très bien le jeu sera plus tôt